going solo as a solo artist um I guess
you finally felt because Paul Simon
talks about this he originally hooked up
with art gar funcle because he needed
somebody else up on stage with him and
my theory with you is I think you kind
of outgrew the band you you and and
successfully went solo because you know
how many artists try that when they're
in a band and it doesn't work they can't
they can't go solo this is everything in
my life is like an evolution and there's
no like like a clear like thought that
Master no and I just remember doing rock
steady and it was the greatest thing
like working with farel and just that
everything went to a different place you
know and also like collaborating with
Eve and Moby and just stepping outside
everything that I did when when I
collaborated was like my favorite stuff
I ever did I mean so I just got this
feeling that I wanted to make a dance
record it wasn't like I was embarrassed
to say I would do a solo record that
would be embarrassing but I wanted to do
music that I grew up on that was not SCA
that was not like not in a band like not
like Punk or whatever so how do you
approach that do you say to yourself
okay I'm going to sit down I'm going to
write some songs and then I'll get in
touch with forel I'll get in touch with
this one or whatever and then we'll
collaborate or do you just collaborate
with them from the beginning I think
that from the beginning Tony knew I
wanted to do it and he was on board and
he sort of I want to say like executive
produced it in the sense that he wrote a
lot with me and then I just I basically
said I want to do the rounds like I want
to how it works with with like pop stars
or whatever is there's all these writers
of the moment and then you go in and you
write with them right and if you're a
writer or if you're not a writer you
just have all these songs sent to you
and you just choose and then you record
them but I wanted to write it don't you
think that's an awful career you can't
write your own music and you have to
rely on others it's a different career
you know so different I mean for me
everything is about my story and and
sharing that and then having that you
know exchange of love that is what I
live for but I think that by going in
and and were it the pressure to go in
the studio on my own to write these
songs with these masters of the moment
was so big and that's why what you're
waiting for was the first song I wrote
which was like Linda Perry saying to me
what are you waiting for Gwen let's go
you know and I was like yeah okay well
I'm just insecure you know what I mean I
just can't help it so and these solo
songs man they go big right I mean it's
like it's it's almost that had to be a
was that a surprise because you had you
know had the comfort and safety of a
band and you guys had had success it it
was scary but I felt there was something
in me that needed needed to do it wanted
to do it and I think that was my most
creative period of my life because I was
completely free to just be
me